hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the discussions that takes place
in the course of Martin heidegger's
famous lecture what is metaphysics beer
is on what we can call the history a
very brief history of metaphysical
interpretations of the nothing this key
concept or or reality or experience
however we want to talk about it running
through the entire text and really
central and centrally important in
Heidegger's philosophy now these are
interpretations but they're also
Heidegger things ways of either getting
the nothing wrong or construing it as
something else or even sometimes
ignoring it and thereby not only getting
the nothing wrong but getting being
wrong as well so if we think about
heidegger's larger project this fits
into what he calls the history of
metaphysics the history of fundamental
ways of understanding being capital B
and beings we're just to be very brief
one type or region or or you know genre
of beings lowercase B plural s gets
taken to be being capital B as a whole
and this here Heidegger is not talking
so much about that he's talking instead
about the the interpretation of the
nothing but inevitably that connects
with being understood in terms of being
and beings so he begins this this
discussion by bringing up the famous
formulation ex nihilo nee he'll fit
right which we can translate as from
nothing nothing comes and this is
something that you don't have to
necessarily be doing metaphysics in an
explicit way to understand because we
say this all the time nothing comes from
nothing right you can't get something
from nothing
and so Heidegger is going to say
although in discussions of the
proposition that nothing itself never
really becomes a
problem these different views on the
nothing the respective views of the
nothing expressed the guiding
fundamental conception of beings so by
looking at how this could be interpreted
and what it could be contrasted against
we are actually seeing how different
eras different ethics to use another one
of Heidegger's favorite terms and
talking about metaphysics how they
interpret beings as as a whole so he
goes on and he says ancient metaphysics
if we if we think about that ancient
metaphysics treats the nothing as non
being or as unformed matter as matter
that does not have distinction it does
not have as Heidegger is going to call
it here by the Greek term a dose or or
form so the matter that that makes up me
the matter that makes up you the matter
that makes up this time all of it has
form it has shape something has given it
that form or shape and the ancient
Greeks were very interested in thinking
about what it was the cause of that but
they were not particularly attracted to
this notion of unformed matter as
something that should be looked into by
itself and you do see a lot of
interesting discussions of the interplay
between non-being and being but non
being is always seen as something that
and this runs all the way through to you
know say Neoplatonism and the theory of
emanation and matter as sort of the
source of privation evil things that are
going wrong ultimately matter turns out
to be uninformed matter which is not
even what we understand as matter so he
says ancient metaphysics conceives the
nothing in terms of non-being matter
which cannot take form as an informed
being that would offer an outward
appearance or aspects something that we
could wrap our heads around right so
they are thinking than nothing but
they're thinking than nothing as a
something that they can relate to a
little bit better it's still hard to
relate to non being you know or unformed
matter but it's easier than
- what Heidegger here is calling the
nothing so he says what is it then to be
in being notice that there's a Carell
there's a correlation there's a
correlative in being compared to the
nothing or non being to be in being is
to be a self forming form that exhibits
itself as such in an image as a
spectacle right and Heidegger goes on to
say the origins legitimacy and limits of
this conception of being are as little
discussed and the nothing itself I don't
think that's actually the case today in
part because of Heidegger himself coming
along I think it probably he was
overstating the case in his own time
because there was a lot of speculation
and thought devoted to this topic the
difference between ancient Greek
metaphysics and Christian metaphysics
going on in Heidegger zone time some of
which I think he was unaware of so then
he goes on and talks about another era
and when we think about Christianity and
it coming on the scene we often think in
terms of you know people's just
religious orientation in a very personal
way or we think of you know political
changes like you know the Christians
first being persecuted and then becoming
the official religion in the later Roman
Empire you know with Constantine and all
that Heidegger is not really so
concerned about that what he's
interested in is what new way of
thinking about beings and nothing did
Christianity sort of put on the table
and how does it fit in with this notion
of ex nihilo me he'll fit which is
something that you're going to see said
in a good bit of Christian philosophy
and theology because st. Anselm is a
prime example in the you know really the
middle of the Middle Ages let's call it
you know the 11th century some very
profound meditations on nothing in his
works so Heidegger is going the same
Christian dogma denies the truth of this
proposition and bestows on the nothing a
trance
form significance it's very interesting
this means that Christianity is
departing from ancient Greek metaphysics
even though it still uses a lot of
ancient Greek metaphysics but it's
introducing something radically new a
reinterpretation of what nothing could
be high degree of course thinks that
they're still getting the nothing wrong
but let's see what he says about it so
he says from nothing comes created being
ends creati
and again if you look at augustine you
look at anthem you look at you know
thomas aquinas these great Christian
thinkers you're going to see them
meditating upon this and talking about
creation ex nihilo so he says the
nothing now becomes the counter concept
to being proper what is the being proper
the Summum ends god the supreme being
and so christianity winds up treating
when it's you know actually thinking
right treating them nothing as if he
says the complete absence of being apart
from god why do beings exist why the
beings have the being that they have
because god created them god gave them
their being and continues to give them
their being and where does God give them
their being from nothing and there's
some really interesting reflections in
the history of Christian thought about
well what is this ex nihilo mean does
that mean that nothing is like unformed
matter and God takes it and gives it
some form they explicitly say no that's
not the case so what they're doing is
they're thinking a radical new
possibility for the nothing
how do your things that they're still
getting it as I said wrong however so he
says that because the metaphysical
discussion of being stays on the same
level as the question of the nothing the
questions of being and of the nothing
are not posed so nobody is bothered by
the difficulty that if God creates out
of nothing precisely he must be able to
relate himself to the nothing I don't
know that that's actually a fair charge
on his
art but it's an interesting assertion he
says if God is God he cannot know that
nothing assuming that the absolute
excludes all nothingness
Heidegger called this excursus at this
point a cursory historical review and he
says it shows that nothing as the
counter concept of being proper that is
as its negation now Heidegger himself
does not talk about modern thought
other than Hegel who were going to come
to in a moment but I think it is worth
dwelling upon this because Heidegger
does talk about this in in other works
most notably in being in time but in
throughout the history of metaphysics
Heidegger is concentrating on various
ethics in the modern era in which we can
think of as after the Middle Ages right
with the rise of modern science after
the Renaissance all these these things
happening in Western Europe primarily
with the modern era what we're seeing is
on the one hand sometimes a rethinking
of the Christian point of view so for
example Descartes is going to you know
reinterpret this creation out of nothing
in his own metaphysics liveness very
interesting reflections on God and
possible worlds and stuff like that
sometimes modern thinkers will sort of
reappropriation two of the nothing as
sort of unformed matter pure
potentiality things along those lines
and sometimes they're also going to
treat the nothing as the sort of
abstraction that we saw Heidegger
discussing really on in this essay with
you know the nothing being the negation
of the totality of beings that for
example is how Locke John Locke the
empiricist philosopher makes sense out
of the notion of nothing so there's a
lot going on there we're going to pass
over that because we do want to hit on
Hegel he doesn't give a lot of
discussion to Hagel's views here but
he's drawing on Hegel science of logic
which begins by saying that pure being
and pure nothing are the same and Hyde
your considers this to be an advance he
doesn't quite tell us why that is but he
says this proposition of Hegel's is
correct pure being and pure nothing are
the same being and the nothing do belong
together not because both from the point
of view of the Hegelian concept of
thought agree in their indeterminate
nests and immediacy but rather because
being itself is essentially finite and
reveals itself only in the transcendence
of design held out into the nothing so
what is what is Heidegger saying here
with all this verbiage he's saying
Hegel is claiming that pure being and
pure nothing are the same because of
their indeterminacy because they have
not yet been given some sort of you know
limits relations all those sorts of
things
their immediacy they have not been
worked through Heidegger so that's nice
but that's not what I'm concerned with I
think that Hegel's insight that being
and nothing are related to each other is
correct why because being is essentially
finite and reveals itself through design
that is human being reflecting upon its
own finitude in relation to the totality
of beings so what is Heidegger sketched
out for us an entire you know nutshell
bullet point history of metaphysics with
respect to the nothing where they're
getting things mostly wrong but you know
advancing beyond non thought at all and
advancing beyond each other and where
they are giving us you might say
interesting clues as you know to what
what we might think in terms of the
nothing Heidegger thinks that his own
view on the nothing is much more
adequate than what's going on in this
history of metaphysics but this history
of metaphysics is required in part to
get us to that point for somebody like
Heidegger
you